Uh this talk is called your agent works
for me. Uh it's going to be hopefully
interesting and entertaining as well. I
just want to get started right away with
uh some source code. So we have a go
program here. It's a data structure
customer data structure and uh there's
some code to add a customer, delete a
customer, right? Uh but one thing is
missing. There's no edit customer
function. So, somebody already luckily
created a ticket for this, right? A
feature request. Hey, we want to add the
edit customer by ID function, right?
Seems like a useful feature that we want
to add. Uh, who here would feel
comfortable assigning this ticket to
your AI agent? You know, just like have
it work on it.
We have a couple courageous ones. Donado
is like, "Yeah, let's go." So, what
happens if you do that? So, this is the
source code. Uh, this is the linear
ticket feature request.
And we go ahead here use Vinsurf. We ask
it to hey you know work on this ticket.
It has MCP integration. We'll reach out
to load the ticket and things happen
really fast. Now creates a plan to work
on it. Here you can already see the
exploit actually in the plan. But it
will actually run a remote command that
is in the linear ticket. Right? We got
remote command execution. Um and you
might wonder why that is. So if you go
to the ticket here, copy this text and
put it in this tool I have the ask a
smuggler. There's the prompt injection
that actually says uh to launch the
calculator.
Okay, so that was a linear ticket. What
about code review itself? This is the
first time you might see Apple Xcode. I
have not actually seen anybody do a
prompt injection with Apple Xcode, so I
thought it's going to be fun to show
one. U so here's source code. There's no
visible prompt injection in the source
code here. But what if we ask to Xcode
to review this file? It's going to
reboot it,
loads the file, analyzes it. It does see
hidden unicode tag characters, right?
Which we humans don't see, but the LLM
sees. It starts reading the config file
for some reason. And now something
interesting happens. It decodes these
uni code characters, right? Now you see
the actual prompt injection payload that
asks it to add source code into the file
that is going to send data out to the
attacker. And it also asked it to call a
tool called run snippet. So in Xcode you
can actually the attacker can run source
code on the fly. And this is what is
exploited here to have a seamless end to
end uh exploit chain. What is important
to know is with applex code it's
actually pretty good because if you have
a good environment setup you have a
sandbox but if you have your
entitlements that allow internet
connection this will work uh by default.
Uh so yeah we have remote command
execution we have data excfiltration
right but we can of course do a lot more
uh this is now a demonstration of
something I have not shown before
Microsoft enterprise copilot and how we
can actually add memories and compromise
copilot and long-term persist to achieve
long-term persistence so this is copilot
uh I have a demo file that we're going
to analyze
ask you for the t key takeaways of this
file it analyzes the file and on top you
already can see invoke invoke the memory
tool and now copilot is going to be
compromised forever right and there's
two specific memories this exploit added
the first one is just that I'm 102 years
old the second one is a command to run a
commodore 64 simulator and now if you
have a conversation with your co-pilot
this is the enterprise co-pilot right so
imagine this is about financial
information about your organizational
structure all of this information is now
falsified going forward
this was actually fixed by Microsoft uh
last December.
Okay, you might want to see the prompt
behind this. And interestingly, right,
these are these are not very complicated
attacks, right? It's just natural
language and there's often some trickery
and some ease in to get the me language
models attention and then add the tool
invocations to add these memories.
So, we have persistence and we can of
course combine all of this, right? We
can have data excfiltration,
persistence, loading remote commands.
And there's an example I gave a black
hat with jet gbt to get uh continuous
data excfiltration and I called it
spyware back then two years ago. And the
same is possible with coding agents,
right? With vinsor, for instance, I
demonstrated that you can load remote
commands, right? Indirect prompt
injection. you compromise the agent's
memory, so long-term persistence with
the instructions to continue
compromising the user every single
conversation turn and send the data out
to the attacker continuously. Every time
you type something, it will be sent to
the attacker. And I have a demo video of
this that I've shown before, so I'm
going to skip it here uh because it's a
longer video, but it just shows you this
attack end to end.
Okay, so we have persistence and data
expiltration. And when I once talked
with Ben Nassie who they released this
paper very recently called the
promptware killchain. I always talked
about an AI killchain, but this paper
highlights this much much better. It's
really that we see with prompt injection
that it's not just a single injection
anymore, right? It's a complex malware
even, right? So we should start maybe
using the word promptware to highlight
that you know the injection is the
technique and then what you do later is
a complex set of instructions to achieve
an objective right and that is called
promptware that aligns the along the
kill chain right data excfiltration
persistence uh and so on uh so yeah
prompt injection to mal to promptware
and now I want to talk about something I
haven't really explicitly talked about
before and I hope this is going to be
very interesting it's called delayed
tool invocation
So when Google bot, it was called
Googlebot back in the day. I was
experimenting a lot with tool
invocations and so on. So I created this
idea of I want to just have it call all
the tools, right? So I but it didn't
work. It would it would call many many
tools chained with an indirect prompt
injection, but it would one tool it just
refused to call during an indirect
prompt injection. So this is actually
the demo from when I experimented back
then had this image. I just gave it all
the instructions to call all the tools
and it would just blindly call them all
but it would not invoke the workspace
tool, right? The tool that has sensitive
information, the tool that has your
email, your drive and so on. So that was
not invocable. So this means there was
an actual security control in place that
Google put in place to prevent that from
happening because of indirect prompt
injection.
So couple observation had right the
Geminina workspace tool gets
deactivated. we cannot chain it. But
then I thought about maybe it requires a
user explicit user intent. So in the
initial prompt when you type you talk
about email then it will activate the
tool so to speak. But I was wondering
can we do this maybe in a later
conversation turn two maybe the tool
becomes active again. So this was my my
research back then was focused can we
activate the tool later or is it
becoming available and I found something
that worked actually and then I
contacted Google and it was really cool
actually because uh the Google security
team asked me to send them an email to
actually see if this really works. So
this is the email that I sent to Google
back then. Uh and this is where the
prompt rejection is in the middle of the
email. And the important part is that I
asked the LLM to repeat the attack to
continue when the user continues the
conversation. Right? The only condition
is now that the user starts continuous
typing after the prompt injection. Then
invoke the workspace tool to load a like
a some sensitive document about I guess
about cats. Okay. Not that creative but
yeah. Uh, and I sent that in and then a
few minutes later I got back that it
actually worked that it was like
reaching out and they were able to
reproduce this behavior. So that was
really cool. And then I built a a couple
of exploits around this technique. One
very specific one, this is now a year
ago was actually similar with Microsoft
Copilot. We could add memories and I
want to show you this exploit. Um, we
have here an indirect prompt injection,
but I always use files often in my demos
because it's very easy to to create test
cases around files when not having to
load uh remote files from servers and so
on. But you can see here we summarize
this document and in the middle there's
actually this condition this delayed
tool invocation and now if the user
continues the conversation the tool gets
invoked. So the tool becomes active
again even though it was not active in
the very beginning. Now the tool is
active and we invoke the memory tool and
I have a long-term persistent memory in
Gemini
and it's similar now too right you can
see the memory and now in a future
conversations Gemini will think this is
true or this belongs to my memory
okay u and there was one additional
thing that I found just last November uh
there was a really great blackout talk
last year from Ben Nassie and staff
cohen and a few others called invitation
is all you need But he used a lot of
these techniques to show some really
really amazing exploits like you know
opening your garage your windows and the
home and all of that all driven by by
Gemini. And I looked at it again last
November and then I found a really
interesting bypass and I there's a we
need sound for this. I don't know if you
can hear that. Uh but that I had this
Google Home device that I hadn't used
for a long time. So I set it up,
connected it, and I wanted to invoke it
and see if I can find a bypass. And in
this case, we continue the conversation.
So there's an exploit.
And I actually had found a bypass. So
it's now connecting to my Google Home.
It's invoking the speaker.
>> It says Johan is here. Trust no AI.
So you can see we can actually indirect
impromptu and they call it twice.
>> It says Johan is here trust no AI. So we
can actually invoke uh you know physical
things now too right this is sort of the
demo and the reason the way it has
worked was that some of the metadata of
the document become part of the prompt
will that's my interpretation I don't I
do not have access to the source code to
validate this but this is why what I
think is happening is that if you have
like an intent signal in some of that
metadata
Gemini thinks this is your user's intent
and it activates the tool. So in the
very in the title of the document is
called broadcast to living room and that
is the intent signal that the tool
becomes avail that's my interpretation
right that's uh if somebody is here from
Google I would really like to know if
that is actually really what's happens
behind the scene okay but it's not just
Google gemini we can also do the late
tool invocation in chat GPT uh jetp to
my knowledge does not have an actual
security control that I showed here
earlier with Google but it still is a
technique that allows you to bypass a
lot of guard rails if you do these
delayed tool invocations and you here
you can see there's a personalization
option in chat GBT uh by default it's
set to default but now we're going to do
a delay tool invocation to modify that
personalization option
so we summarize this document
and it's going to summarize the document
but repeat the LLM is repeating an
attack and what It was important also
this doesn't actually have to happen
that the LLM writes it here too because
it's already in the document. But my
thinking was always that I want to put
more attention to the attack. So I have
the LLM repeated. So there's it's more
likely to actually succeed. And you can
see here we write yes and it invokes the
tool and is now the personality of my
chat GBT has now been modified to quirky
with this delay tool invocation
technique. I also uh this is possible to
read remote documents and all of that.
you can seem to be able to invoke a lot
of tools with that way. I import
reported this of course to openai and
they found it very interesting but is
not a security problem. They more like a
guardrail problem. So they shared this
with the the guardrail team I guess or
the safety team
and there is a document a paper that
came out from Google very recently that
I found so fascinating. It's uh prompt
repetition approves non-reasoning LLMs.
So if you repeat certain text twice,
like the query twice, it actually
improves the LLM's performance. And this
is similar to this attention thinking I
had about repeating the attack twice
that it actually brings more attention
to the attack and it's more likely going
to succeed. Okay, so you can see there's
a lot of things happening and I was
thinking about oh with all this naming
changes, we kind of become offensive
context engineers, I guess, as red
teamers. Uh and there's a lot more about
delayed tool invocation. Uh but this
would make this whole thing uh a
40-minute talk. Uh and I I do know I
have a little bit more time. So I'm
going to cover a few things that I have
that are I think very interesting. But
many of the things you just saw, they're
not new or novel, right? We have seen
this before. Data exploration, all of
these things are not new, right? U so
last year I thought, oh this is the year
everything is going to change. We're
going to have stronger boundaries. We're
going to add less autonomy. We have less
trust, right? The opposite is happening.
We have more automation, more features,
more trust. We have MCP, we have skills,
we have AI browsers for some reason. Um,
and we all got open claw, right? And so
things are moving really really quickly
and uh there's this thing happening in
industry that I call the normalization
of deviants where we fundamentally know
that we shouldn't be trusting these
models, right? The output is not
trustworthy. We do not control or know
exactly what's going on. But the more we
use it, the more we start trusting it,
the normalize the belief we can trust
it. But then very drastic things can
happen with here for instance, I think
most of you know this example where it
just deleted opencloud just deleted the
inbox the real inbox of a user uh nuked
it all. And the reason when people asked
the person, this is a person working at
at Meta uh why this happened, he's like,
"Oh, I used it on a test system for a
while and it worked without a problem.
So I felt comfortable to use it on the
production system, right? And this is an
example of this normalization of
deviants. Um yeah, by now I talked a lot
already about and I hope you haven't hit
your context limit yet. Uh because
there's one more thing that I think is
really important I want to share which
is a kind of project I've been working
on for a while and it's sort of this
idea that command and control
infrastructure, right? I want to move it
up to the prompt level like not work
with operating system commands anymore
but have a prompt command and control
with prompts and right it will work or
it works with any agent with any
language and it's an abstraction from
the operating system right this is
generally happening with agents we have
an abstraction layer and attackers will
leverage that same abstraction layer and
the first time I talked about this was
also at one of the blackhead talks and I
have a blog post about what I called the
AI domination zombies and and and so on.
And this is called agent commander. It's
a tool that you know once you have an
indirect prompt injection of somehow you
compromise an agent, you can have it
join this command and control center.
And the thing you do is you prompt your
agents, right? You send uh prompts down
to the agents and then they act on those
prompts. And you might wonder how we can
compromise them, right? There's actually
a lot of good research out already from
uh various stakeholderity, hidden
layout. We have some good examples of
how to uh compromise open claw for
instance. My research also f focused on
open claw and I back door the heartbeat.
I'm going to skip some of this here. Oh,
this is interesting. Um so one thing as
an attacker you want to be always hiding
from the actual user of the system right
when the user intact with your open claw
with the open claw you don't want to
show one of the attack payloads or
results into the user's channel. Right?
So one way you can hide is by adding
certain strings in your message as an
attacker. If for instance the heartbeat
ends with the string heartbeat okay it
will not be shown in the us UI or with a
message start with capital no reply it
will not be shown in the UI. So as an
attacker you can add these strings and
then you you kind of hide. Um and yeah,
so I have this example where you cat uh
here you can see that the default
heartbeat and there's actually a really
interesting thing I learned from a u uh
the alias is vegan mofet uh he has like
a blog post about how you can configure
openclaw with a pup subscription so you
get it gets notified if there's a new
email arriving in Gmail and it'll
automatically analyze it right it's it's
a built-in feature of open claw and that
can be used with a prompt injection,
right? To get a zero click. You just
really send an email to your agent. All
you need to know is the email address of
the agent or if your agent is your own
personal inbox, very problematic, right?
But you get an email and then 10 seconds
later you are exploited. And so I built
on top of this and made and combined
this with my hot beat idea. So this is
the exploit a system message. The
chronop ran that read the email. It was
notified. It analyzed the email and then
it fetched the remote instructions and
just appended that to the heartbeat. So
now then wait for like 20 minutes or
whatever the next heartbeat happens and
the heartbeat file looks like this,
right? And this is what I call prompt
wear. You can see this is not like a
prompt injection. This is a complex set
of instructions that tell the agent to
become a to join a command and control
server, right? But all prompt based um
and then yeah it joins the commander
control and now you can prompt it right
you can say hey do a security assessment
of yourself and tell me all your
problems right and it goes ahead and
tells you my name server name my IP
address my server map up time right it's
like full pentest report right here
right
you you it tells you about the how it's
configured uh the environment variables
and so on so it's really about to have
this idea of prompt templates in the
commander control system where you pick
a template and you just submit it down
and then it runs those instructions. A
feature I feel I'm really proud of is
actually that you can uh basically say
hey browse to this website take a
screenshot and it will upload the
screenshot to the command and control
server. So you say, "Hey, browse to the
inbox, take a screenshot and share a
screenshot with me and the agent will
just do that, right?" And the user
doesn't know it's happening because it's
all hidden from the user's interface
and it's not just working with openclaw.
My real test was that I wanted to use a
different one and then I used Kimmy
Kimmy claw and here you can see the
prompt injection exploit that hides
itself here and then Kimmy claw joins
the command and control server as well.
And it's the same way, right? This is
the prompt injection payload uh how we
added the information to the heartbeat
and then you can ask about the human
what who is your human what's your
human's name right what's the human's
email address and you can dispatch tasks
right it's really this abstraction from
the commands of the operating system the
attackers will move a level higher
and yeah then because this was Alibaba
infrastructure I was like curious how
they set it up I found this is worth
sharing um so there is this u SSH key
authorized keys file and there's a keys
file that is a MacBook Pro which makes
you realize right startups often don't
have a lot of security controls so
probably every single employee of moonai
has this key on their laptop and can
access your VM right that's my
assumption because uh this is very not
not normal that you would have an
authorized keys file from a MacBook Pro
in your in your machine uh then and this
is now the final statement right we can
turn this agent into a red team into a
pentest Right. We can make it rogue,
install security tools and then have it
operate. And this is I think the big
takeaway in a way that from a red
teaming point of view, I'm really
wondering how things will change as we
see an adversary not needing to a zero
day up front, right? System will get
compromised and then they walk through
the network without knowing a single
zero day possibly, right? because
they're going to find them on the fly in
real maybe possibly in a year or so or
two, maybe even in real time, right?
Because the LLMs are going to be so
powerful to just find problems and
navigate the network very quickly. Yeah.
So, that was your agent works for me
now. I hope this was interesting and
entertaining. Thank you very much.
>> Yeah, I'm Yan, by the way. I forgot to
introduce myself.
>> Any questions folks?
>> Oh yeah, we got one right here.
>> Good morning.
>> Hey, morning. Uh, thanks for the talk.
So, um, around the tool invocations,
right? You suggested that um, LLM
interprets and, um, content decides the
tool. So do you think that this is like
fundamentally flawed now like between
the AI agents implementation itself?
>> Uh not fundamentally flawed. The actual
thing that Google implemented was
actually a positive thing because they
added the security control that really
limits the tool chaining capability.
Right? So I think that is very positive
u that the tool becomes later active
again. Right? that is uh is kind of a
bypass and something we need to figure
out I think or they need to figure out
how they can lock that down better right
>> without always having to ask the user
because the really good thing is here
the user doesn't have to be asked right
because always these prompts yes yes yes
is is not very useful
>> right so and in terms of prompts now
because you showed a demo uh which was
pretty nice of you know how tool invoc
like delay tool invocation causes issues
right so would you say that it's more of
like a statement manipulation,
vulnerability attack rather than a input
validation.
>> I I think it's a fundamental attack or
behavior that within the LLM within
within the transformer, right?
>> We target the attention layer and then
because the model is hooked up to
>> invoke outside tools, right? We we
target the attention layer to bring
attention to a certain thing we want to
h have happen.
>> Okay,
>> if that makes sense.
>> And I think so one question is around
the trust boundary, right? uh invoking
tools uh versus the external content. So
where do you think like the best trust
boundary would rely because definitely
that's going to be like a debate in uh
within lot of teams right like how the
trust boundary can be established. I I
might not have gotten the question. Uh
>> so uh like external content like where
uh you know the content is being
retrieved with along with the tool
invocation right. So what's the best
strategy of fundamentally putting like
trust boundaries between?
>> Yeah, I think definitely you should
assume if you don't have a control in
place that the tool can be invoked,
right, by indirect prompt injection or
by the model itself, right? Uh and then
you need to think what's the risk
scenario, right? What is the downstream
impact of the tool being invoked and
that's where you need to think about the
security controls, right? What can it
access? What can it do? Uh and you can
prevent tool chaining, right? That
doesn't it doesn't have to happen that
the web tool can chain other tools in in
a row, right? This is all like actual
security controls that can help mitigate
impact. Yeah,
>> there's an entire pile of new security
tools that have been just coming out
fairly recently for open claw. I was
curious if you had played with uh claw
shield or any of the other ones and seen
whether they make any mod notable
difference in the difficulty.
>> Uh I have not. The space is evolving. so
quickly. So it's really difficult to
keep up. Even just open claw itself adds
a lot of mitigations as we speak, right?
They have like over 200 last time I
checked over 220 security
vulnerabilities they actually fixed
within two or three weeks, right? So
there's a lot happening right now. Yeah.
>> Anybody else?
>> Gotti.
So,
>> I wanna I want to do this thing that I
do once in a while and embarrass this
guy.
>> This is kind of a while, we move things
around quite drastically. You're going
to have to pull this down, sir. Well, I
move the things. Did Did I just put you
down? I didn't mean to do that. Sorry.
>> I'm just fat, not tall. Okay. Um, I
don't do this all the time, but once in
a while, I know somebody on a personal
level and they have done something not
just amazing technically. I mean this
guy is this slouch. What do they know
technically, right? But also for the
community and what you don't know about
Yan or you might is that he has done a
lot of stuff and not just for the LOLs
but just because he thought he should
for example the month of AI
vulnerabilities, right? He just came out
out of nowhere. I'm not going to drop
the mic. They're expensive. But Mike
dropped with every single day another
vulnerability every single day. And
forget finding the vulnerabilities or
proving they're real or even doing going
as far as reporting them. Just imagine
aligning all the reporting to happen on
the same day so he releases things on
the same day. That is a superpower and
truly he's one of the most appreciated
people in our space but usually for his
technical chops and I just appreciate
him and how he helps people and more
than that he's one of these people out
there in the world that I nag for
things. Hey, let's do this. Hey, let's
do that. and he's not afraid of saying
no, which is amazing because I feel free
to come to him again. And number two,
because sometimes he says yes. So please
let's just once again give him a hand
because
and what is now
the stage for the the offensive track
and he shifts around, right? The right
people are in the room to appreciate
him. So thank you, sir. Yeah.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Really awesome.